os presentamos a teodoro obiang el
dictador favorito de todos los políticos
españoles
teodoro obiang es el presidente de
guinea ecuatorial si eso es un país y
está aquí es una antigua colonia
española en donde el petróleo les sale
por las orejas por supuesto tanto él
como el resto de su familia están entre
los más ricos de toda áfrica sin embargo
el 70 por ciento de la población vive
por debajo del umbral de la pobreza hay
muchas razones por las que indignarse
con este hombre hoy vamos a contarte las
vio un día que en este país no hay
pobreza
habría lo que yo califico como penuria
produce 346 mil barriles de petróleo al
día su producto interno bruto per cápita
es el más alto de todo áfrica y estaría
cerca de países como portugal lituania o
corea del sur
exactamente alberto para que no lo sepa
línea ecuatorial fue una provincia de
españa hasta 1968 es muy lejos de españa
es las selvas de áfrica bajo los cielos
blanquecinos del ecuador donde la
guardia colonial presta servicio al pie
de las banderas por eso es el único país
africano donde la lengua oficial es el
español durante las décadas posteriores
los guineanos subsistían exportando
cacao café y frutas tropicales en el año
1996 se realizarán las primeras
extracciones de petróleo en el país
desde entonces su economía no ha dejado
de crecer sin embargo en guinea
ecuatorial el 70% de la población vive
bajo el umbral de la pobreza porque la
respuesta tiene un nombre
teodoro obiang bueno
puedo certificar la posición de las
organizaciones internacionales
teodoro obiang llegó al poder cargándose
al que era por aquel entonces el
presidente de guinea
francisco macías un sanguinario
reconocido admirador de hitler que
casualmente además era su tío entre
comillas libertad de expresión desde
entonces desde 1979 todo lo habían
llevado sentando el cargo de presidente
de guinea ininterrumpidamente eso le
hace ser en la actualidad el presidente
que más tiempo lleva en el cargo 36 años
durante este tiempo
obvian no le ha temblado el pulso para
ejercer una tremenda represión policial
contra sus adversarios políticos se
prefiere que uno mate antes de hablar de
política la presión de playa negra en la
isla de bioko es una de las más
terribles del mundo los casos de
torturas se cuentan por miles a los
presos políticos se les juega por los
tobillos durante horas y se les llega
todo tipo de cuidado médico con la
flecha del carbón seriamente aunque me
hayan dado la espalda yo subo mientras
fuertemente
ese no sale
en línea se celebran elecciones lo
cierto es en la práctica es una pero
dictadura o bien no ha obtenido menos
del 90 por ciento del respaldo de los
votos cada vez que está presentado yo
creo que no sé si el hecho de que haya
un dirigente longevo en el poder es lo
que llaman dictadura pero nosotros
tenemos la aceptación del pueblo de
guinea ecuatorial pero todos tenemos la
aceptación del pueblo de guinea
ecuatorial beijing
porque mire con
la familia de obiang guarda una fortuna
en el exterior que puede ascender a
miles de millones de dólares sólo en
eeuu la justicia localizó una cuenta en
el banco riggs de nueva york con 700
millones de dólares procedentes del
petróleo mientras teodoro obiang se
gasta 55 millones de dólares en un
boeing 737 con baños de oro en guinea
ecuatorial la gente vive con menos de 2
dólares al día
las bolas como es es esta mujer asegura
llevar varios días sin agua corriente
sin embargo y que no se atreve a
hablarle a la cámara sin embargo la
estrella de la familia estío döring uno
de los 42 hijos reconocidos de teodoro
vía teodorín abrigado a tener un
patrimonio de 300 millones de dólares en
eeuu que incluía a 32 coches deportivos
una mansión de malibú y cerca de 2
millones de dólares en objetos de
coleccionista de michael jackson y es
que además presume de ese nivel de vida
en redes como instagram donde
periódicamente comparte públicamente en
la vida que se pega todos le apuntan
como el próximo sucesor de su padre
actualmente ostenta el cargo de
vicepresidente viva libia expedido
la línea perfecta sin embargo hace un
par de años el departamento de justicia
de eeuu obligó a teodorín a vender un
ferrari la residencia que éste poseían
los ángeles y seis estatuas de michael
jackson a tamaño real en una operación
contra el lavado de dinero eso sí el
departamento de justicia le permitió
conservar uno de los famosos guantes de
cristales de michael jackson
guinea experimentó como consecuencia del
petróleo según el fondo meta
internacional su producto interior bruto
creció de media a un 40% al año entre
1996 y 2006 esto no tiene precedente es
una historia por desgracia los guineanos
no hubieron nada de este dinero mientras
que su pib per cápita es el más alto de
áfrica tres de cada cuatro personas
viven bajo el umbral de la pobreza las
inversas en sanidad educación o
desarrollo profesional no existen en
cambio o bien destina todos los
petrodólares a faraónicos proyectos como
hoy a la una nueva ciudad que está
construyendo en la profundidad de la
selva al doctor rodríguez nos acusó de
haber emprendido proyectos faraónicos
dios lo que tiene de faraónico haber
hecho construir esas tres magníficas
pirámides
espera mover la capital del país hasta
allí para evitar posibles golpes de
estado como el de al año desde 2009 la
democracia no es el desorden no es la
guerra actualmente la zona consta de un
hotel de lujo con 450 nuevas
habitaciones y algunos edificios vacíos
en los que ellos pretenden que se
instalen universidades internacionales
sin embargo la caída en el precio el
petróleo está perjudicando a la
financiación de estos proyectos
megalómanos como es el caso de lluvia la
catastrófica la situación catastrófica
se prefiere que uno mate antes de hablar
de política como veíamos en el caso de
botsuana ésta era un caso de éxito por
sus instituciones sin embargo en el caso
de guinea podemos comprobar qué pasa
cuando tenemos todo lo contrario por
mucha riqueza natural que tenga un
territorio la falta de instituciones que
amparen la propiedad privada y protejan
la libertad y mengua individual hacen
que un país se convierta en el cortijo
particular de moscú